[Música]
[Aplausos]
cráter
el mundo no está mal porque los malos
sean malos sino por la indiferencia y la
apatía de los buenos
mi experiencia y mi aventura en el
emprendimiento social comienza cuando
tenía 19 años vendiendo galletitas en
los pasillos de mi universidad iba con
un paquete diario de esas que venden en
el casco de chispas de chocolate
buenísima pero te va ofreciendo a todo
mundo que se me ponía enfrente pero
solamente está vendiendo galletas
también está dándole asesorías a niños
de secundaria que han estado vendiendo
boletos de conciertos también está
organizando eventos y la ayuda a una
amiga con su negocio de comida y me daba
cierta comisión yo estaba haciendo todo
esto porque haya recaudado el dinero
para irme de misiones y de voluntarias a
diferentes partes de méxico es algo que
me encanta y desde que tengo memoria
desde que tengo 9 años me ha estado
yendo
pero bueno al mismo tiempo estaba
estudiando entonces estaba volviendo
loca con todo esto no me estaba
concentrando y decidí hacer una sola
cosa que me dejara dinero y no muchas
donde me distraje era así es como empecé
mi negocio
de amapolas na es una marca de ropa de
sudadera y de blusas claro que al
principio no soy absolutamente nada de
esto esta gestión de ingeniería y
biotecnología me puso a investigar qué
es y proveedores que ese tipos de tela
que ese tipo de impresión y bueno me
gustó tanto esta parte de negocios que
me terminé cambiando de carrera
licenciatura en creación y desarrollo de
empresas
después después de haber comenzado con
polana conozco al padre charles ya lo
mutua quien es el fundador del orfanato
que luche y actualmente un muy buen
amigo y bueno le expresó al padre la el
sueño que yo tenía desde los 13 años de
irme de voluntaria a áfrica el padre me
dice buenísimo y eficaz bienvenida a mi
orfanato ahora le puedes apoyar con algo
económicamente hablando pues te lo
agradecería mucho
y yo soy padre sabéis que es que tengo
19 años estoy estudiando no soy
millonaria no es como que te puedo
sentar a cada bando está verdad pero
pues déjame lo que puedo hacer aguanta
me me puso a pensar en cuáles eran mis
medios y qué puede hacer con ellos para
ayudar al padre y pues acaba de empezar
con mi negocio mi marca de ropa polana y
se me ocurrió sacar unas playeras con
diseños de niños de áfrica venderlas y
que todo se donará al orfanato así que
reunió un grupo de amigos que estuvieron
interesados en formar parte del proyecto
y así fue como empezó hip hop y un poco
es un proyecto social conformado por
jóvenes donde vendemos playeras con
diseños de causas sociales para ayudar a
diferentes causas nuestro principal
proyecto ahorita es el del orfanato
carlos iii ubicado en kenia stefanatto
tiene 80 niños huérfanos desde los 3
hasta los 14 años y son niños que son
huérfanos porque sus padres murieron a
causa del sida que me está infectado de
sida desgraciadamente mucho de estos
padres cuando los hijos nacieron también
los contagiaron incidentes hay niños en
el orfanato que padecen de sida también
son niños que ponen rescatados de la
calle
o son niños que fueron rescatados de sus
casas porque los maltratados me gustaban
de ellos sexualmente o con suerte
conviene una vez al día y dormían sobre
el suelo
lo que todo lo que se recauda
primeramente de las playeras de don al
orfanato y se utiliza para cubrir las
necesidades básicas de estos niños como
no son comida alimentos ropa servicios
del orfanato o los salarios de los
maestros y me da mucho gusto decir que
gracias al apoyo de toda la gente que se
ha solidarizado con nuestro proyecto y
porque van siendo de los principales
sustentos económicos del orfanato
durante los últimos dos años
después de estar trabajando con hip hop
tengo la maravillosa oportunidad de irme
de voluntaria a kenia que más adelante
les platicar un poco sobre eso regreso y
empiezan a invitar a dar pláticas que
luego se convirtieron en conferencias
sobre mi experiencia del emprendimiento
social llevo ya un año dando
conferencias alrededor de mexico
platicando sobre este tema dando
conferencias me di cuenta de lo mucho
que me gustaba dar un mensaje y del
enorme potencial que tiene el testimonio
o la voz de cada uno de nosotros así que
decido exponenciar lo utiliza una
herramienta tan fuerte y tan poderosa
como lo son las redes sociales así que
hace medio año empiezo a compartir
contenido en redes sociales a crear
contenido con un tema que me apasiona
que es el de empoderamiento de la mujer
el feminismo y el amor propio
y bueno después de una serie de eventos
afortunados y de mucho esfuerzo y de
como increíblemente una cosa va dando a
otra pues hemos aquí
quisiera retornar me un poquito lo que
les conté y practicarle sobre mi
experiencia que definitivamente marcó mi
comunidad
la experiencia
como les platiqué es un de hip hop para
2015 y después de dos años de estar
trabajando apoyando a los niños del
orfanato finalmente con el corazón muy
muy feliz y a punto de llorar
literalmente de la emoción a cada
momento
finalmente conocí a los niños del
orfanato carlos iii
pone serios sentimientos encontrados
porque
para nuestra sorpresa llegamos pero
orfanato y los niños estaban viviendo en
condiciones inhumanas
esto es una foto de las camas donde
dormían los niños el colchón si es que
se le puede llamar así pues está todo
desplazado no destruido los niños
prácticamente dormían sobre los tubos o
las tablas de la litera había un olor
tan fuerte y tan desagradable en el
dormitorio que era difícil quedarte ahí
los niños ya no tenían comida yo vi la
bodeguita donde donde guardaban todos
los sacos de comida y quedaba nada más
uno prácticamente les voy a alcanzar
para una semana
los niños estaban descalzos
no tenían zapatos o los que sí tenían
eran de diferentes tallas o de zapatos y
de pares diferentes
los niños no tenían electricidad no
tenían juguetes
esta es una foto de su balón de fútbol
son unas bolsas de plástico hechas bolas
y amarradas con un mecate
este es otro juguetito que construyó
john y es uno de los huérfanos más
pequeños del orfanato y se me hace una
imagen muy fuerte porque él mismo
construyó su juguete un carrito a base
de una caja de cartón unos palillos y
unas tapas
llevamos solamente unas cuantas horas de
haber llegado al orfanato haber llegado
a kenia ya teníamos una tarea en lo
grande
tenemos que hacer algo al respecto de
esa situación
decidimos comprarle 80 colchones a todos
los niños un colchón por mí cada colchón
válido equivalente a 180 pesos mexicanos
en total eran aproximadamente 9 mil
pesos más mucho sin embargo no podemos
ponerlo en nuestra cartera porque vamos
con el presupuesto muy limitado para
nuestro voluntariado así que decidimos
subir todas estas fotos que les pase a
nuestro grupos de whatsapp o a nuestros
estados de facebook pidiéndole a sus
familiares oa nuestros amigos cercanos
que nada que hay quien 180 pesos por
cada persona que van a los 180 pesos le
mandaremos una foto del niño
agradeciendo por una cartulina que
dijeras thank you jessica fernández for
my new ver hicimos hoy 80 colchones
9.000 pesos en total tenemos todo un mes
para hacer esto vamos a recaudar los
claro que podemos ahora ánimo
queremos recaudar nueve mil pesos en un
mes que vamos hasta ahí
para nuestra sorpresa después de subir
estas fotos en menos de dos semanas ya
hemos recaudado medio millón de pesos
la campaña se hizo viral las fotos de
los niños se hicieron virales recibimos
donaciones de todos los estados de la
república mexicana y de más de 10 países
diferentes de repente el problema ya no
era de dónde sacar dinero sino qué hacer
con tanto dinero
prácticamente remodelamos todo el
orfanato
ahí están algunos niños con sus
colchones de steven hands all for you
beth estén sin 7 sepúlveda les compramos
colchones a los niños ahí está muy bien
contento estrenando no solamente sus
colchones no también sábanas colchas
ventanas también hay atrás
se compró comida para el resto del año
se pagan los salarios de los maestros se
los pagaron las deudas del orfanato se
puso electricidad en todo el orfanato se
compraron utensilios de comida útiles
escolares ropa para los niños uniformes
baños ventanas se pintó el orfanato se
hizo una brigada médica se les compro
medicinas a los niños a los que estaban
enfermos se les dio seguimiento
ustedes compraron dos pares de zapatos a
cada niño uno se sigue como estilo del
constructor para que aguanten y no saca
más formaron es de estilo thompson para
diario
e
entre muchas muchas otras cosas más
disimula verdades que puede algo
increíble completamente sorprendente la
respuesta de la gente pero como les
comenté pues esperamos que hablaran 70
personas 80 personas por cada colchón
para nuestro proyecto al final de un
amor más de 1000 personas entonces pues
claro que no pudimos mandarle la foto
del niño ahora diciendo personalmente
cada una de las personas que donaron
porque después porque para empezar nos
acabamos va a sacar las cartulinas y los
marcadores del pueblo además o veíamos
que hacíamos que el dinero o tomábamos
un millón de fotos y además después de
tener al niño posando con su cartulina
dos horas ya no salía así ya ha salido
así en la foto
entonces por esta razón decidimos pues
no podíamos andar la foto acaban las
personas que donaron y estos
sorprendentemente causó mucho mucho
enojo mucha molestia en muchas de las
personas que donaron a la gente que
exigía la foto del niño agradeciendo
hubo gente que se molestó tanto o no
puede recibir su foto que tuvimos que
ofrecerle devolverle su dinero a la
gente que te habla y te decía hola oye
qué tengo que hacer para que manos de
foto en línea aplican ahora diciéndome
haya gente que te da lado y te decía hoy
aquí está mil 180 pesos te encargo que
porque porfa me mandes la foto este
ángulo o tenga lo que sea en niña y no
un niño el de la foto o tengamos que
poner un nombre a mi empresa o ahí si me
puedes mandar para antes del martes de
lo agradecería
y aquí yo quiero reflexionar un poco
estás donando porque quieres ayudar a
los niños o está sonando porque quieres
una foto tus redes sociales y presumir
que eres una buena persona
ayudar del corazón aunque suene cliché
es ayudar sin esperar nada a cambio para
ayudar sin exigir nada es darle algo a
alguien aún sabiendo que esa persona no
puede darte nada de regreso
cuando íbamos esperando algo a cambio
realmente no estamos ayudando estamos
intercambiando estamos negociando
la felicidad de la persona que recibe
debe ser la mayor recompensa para la
persona que da
y así como la gente que donaba 180 pesos
y exigía la foto del niño agradeciendo
hubo gente que donó 18 mil 20 mil 30 mil
pesos sin siquiera conocernos y nos
decían
no te preocupes no quiero nada no me
mandes mi foto ni quiero ni mi no mi
nombre en ningún lado
felicidades y gracias
dar por el placer verdad
la próxima vez que ayudemos a alguien en
lugar de hacerlo esperando alguna
recompensa ayudemos dando las gracias
por la vida nos puso en el lugar del que
ayuda y no el que necesita ser ayudado
también quisiera compartir la filosofía
de vida la cual me impulsa y me motiva
todos los días a involucrarme en este
tipo de proyectos sociales y como nos ha
contado pues desde muy de desde muy niña
medio misionera voluntaria y por esto me
ha tocado ir muy de cerca las enormes
injusticias o contrastes que hay en
nuestra sociedad y vivo no te tienes que
ir a áfrica ni de misiones para eso
simplemente salimos aquí y vamos a un
oxxo queremos una señora tirada en la
entrada con su bebé cargándolo pidiendo
limosna y luego llegar un señor en su
carro último modelo y bajar se ha
comprado unos cigarros desde ahí vamos a
ser testigos de las enormes diferencias
sociales que hay en nuestro mundo
aquí voy con todo esto
esta es una pregunta que desde hace
mucho tiempo me he hecho y que me he
podido encontrar respuestas
por qué
es una pregunta tan simple pero que
involucra tanto
por qué
porque hay un niño en áfrica huérfano
con sida pasando hambre te pidiendo que
te vender unas playeras para tener algo
que comer y porque están ustedes aquí
sentados escuchando porque estoy yo aquí
hablándoles a ustedes con mi propia casa
con mi familia que me quiere con mi
propio cuarto yendo a la universidad
saliendo los fines de semana a cenar o
de fiesta con mis amigas
por qué
que hice yo o que deje de hacer yo que
ese es el niño o queda 4 este niño para
que él esté esa situación y yo esté aquí
en esta posición
es algo que me causa mucha angustia que
se me hace muy injusto me da mucho
coraje digo por qué por qué por qué
y la respuesta es
no sé
yo soy católica y creo que esta va a ser
la primera pregunta que le haga a dios
por qué
sin embargo mientras tanto mientras siga
no vamos a saber bajo qué términos o
condiciones se dicta como donde nos toca
vivir y acepté creo lo voy a saber
pero como hizo farid bien no está él
porque si no el para qué
no sé por qué prestado en esta posición
me siento con la responsabilidad de
hacer algo con los medios que dios me
dio que me dio la vida buda al universo
como casinos de a quien dependiendo de
sus términos de sus creencias
pero hacer algo algo para ayudar a esas
personas que por cosas del destino o por
suerte no les tocó estar en la misma
posición que yo
y eso es lo que los invito a ustedes y
para eso es esta práctica sienten un
compromiso social una responsabilidad
moral de hacer algo con lo que tienen
para ayudar a aquellos que no lo tienen
creo que lo mínimo que podemos hacer
para esa realidad por lo que nos dio
y no estoy diciendo que se hayan a
áfrica por ejemplo y que empezar una
fundación o que mantengan un orfanato no
no estoy diciendo construir la
biblioteca o beca a 100.000 niños o
conseguir escuela no
para ayudar no tienes que hacer nada
extraordinario ni nada que esté fuera de
tu alcance
hay una parte que me gusta mucho método
roosevelt que hice
haz lo que puedas con lo que tengas y
donde estés
cualquier persona puede ayudar no tienes
que ser millonario no tienes que tener
un título de habilidades especiales o
haber tomado un curso para ayudar a
cualquier persona puede ayudar hagas lo
que hagas tenga lo que tenga que estés
en donde estés puedes ayudar sabes
porque por el simple hecho de que aquí
estás
así que haz algo
busca cuáles son tus medios y qué puedes
hacer con ellos y haz algo
puedes ver mis medios pues yo tenía mi
negocio de playeras decidí hacer unos
diseños de niños de áfrica los verdes
pueden ser baratos
no estamos haciendo una extraordinaria y
al mismo tiempo si estamos en algo
extraordinario nuestro órgano
extraordinario porque así vender las
playeras está entre mis medios y mis
posibilidades hasta mi negocio facilito
pero al mismo tiempo si estamos haciendo
nuestro ordinario porque lo estamos
cambiando la calidad de vida no es de 80
niños huérfanos al otro lado del mundo
pero ven que no es difícil la ayuda
qué es lo que te gusta hacer
cuáles son tus medios que lo que te
apasiona para qué eres bueno y cómo
puedes poner todo eso al servicio de la
humanidad
te aseguro que el mundo necesita lo que
sea que tengas para ofrecerle
y que mucha falta nos hace
y si alguna vez piensas que lo que
tienes que ofrecerle al mundo es poco es
irrelevante es insignificante quisiera
cerrar con esta frase del escritor
eduardo galeano que dice
mucha gente pequeña en lugares pequeños
haciendo cosas pequeñas puede cambiar el
mundo así que los invito a hacer lo que
puedan con lo que tengan y donde estén
para cambiar el mundo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]